Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday April 26. Today's video blog comes in five parts.
Part 1: Papa. It's his birthday, you need
to call him. Part 2: speaking of old people,
Helen Hunt is on your guilt free three list? Helen Hunt? Helen Hunt? Hank, I just
like to remind you that cougar hunting is not legal in the United States.
But anyway Hank, you're talking about your celebrity do list as another commenter
called it reminded me of number 3: my
own celebrity do list which I keep,
of course, in my copy of "How to be a lady" in your pants.
Now let's see if we can find it in here. Uh, there it is.
Ok Hank, we have Natalie Portman, perfectly acceptable. Jenna Fischer from "The Office",
Pam, the only thing I like more than the idea of Pam and Jim getting together:
Pam and John getting together. Then of course we have Judy Blume.
I mean she's cute, she's really cute and
one time at a conference she kissed me
on the cheek and I liked it and I like her and I'm not going to talk about it anymore.
Ok maybe you get a pass on Helen Hunt. Part 4: moving. Hank, I'm sorry to hear
that your house is on the block. I have
good news, though. I think that you should
buy a house but not in Missoula. Specifically I think you should buy a
house in Indianapolis, Indiana. You want to know why? Because I'm moving there.
Sarah got a job at the Indianapolis
Museum of Art, which is really one of the
most exciting contemporary art spaces in America and we're really psyched to go there,
uhm, but I'm a little worried because I
don't have any friends in Indianapolis
and I think I'm going to miss New York. Although if you think about it,
Indianapolis is like the New York of
Indiana and also I'm told that it's got
really good urban exploring. Plus
yesterday I was looking on the internet
and houses in Indianapolis are almost
free. Part 5: Hank, I liked your Eco Geek
podcast animation introduction so much that I've been thinking that maybe we
could have a shorter, more visual
animation for Brotherhood 2.0
that maybe doesn't spell communication wrong.
Maybe you and one of the nerdfighters can get on it. I do it myself except I'm
bad at animating and plus, I have to figure out how I'm gonna move to Indianapolis
with all these books.
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.